T minus nine months until Super Bowl
Sunday hundreds of Las Vegas businesses
are trying to get an NFL contract to add
the big game to their resumes and his 8
news now reporter Ryan Matthews shows us
they met face to face with those
potential employers for the first time
today
how do we stand out in a city that is
met to stand out RJ Orr is tasked with
all the posters signs and Graphics that
will be covering Allegiant stadium in
nine months time his company blue media
is the main Decor planner for the NFL
understand what it's like to get a phone
call at midnight on a Saturday it says I
need this in six hours you know props
florals catering janitorial and Carol
Ann laferte's company on location is
tasked with pregame Hospitality both on
and off site when we ask for something
do it because those who don't respond we
don't respond to sometimes and they're
looking to fill a tall order bring Las
Vegas its first Super Bowl and Thursday
200 of those local Las Vegas businesses
vying for that opportunity whatever you
think you know you don't know small and
diverse businesses vetted by the NFL are
now meeting face to face with the NFL
vendors who could potentially offer them
a job so they need to be competitive in
pricing they need to be competitive in
service because Maisha Boyce with the
Las Vegas Super Bowl host committee says
the local opportunity has National eyes
on them I tell you what's going to be
done today it's it'll be done today but
with only so many opportunities business
owners like Nar Galvez are pitching
themselves to get the job done and get a
name-dropping experience on their resume
doing anything for NFL would open up a
lot of doors and looks good on us